america the uh the health care component
in the american rescue plan permanent
and of course the 12 states that have
not expanded medicaid could certainly
choose to do that as well with that oh
let me just note too all of you know
angela but for those of you who don't
know angela she's one of our press
assistants she went to georgetown i did
not get into georgetown she's very smart
obviously
she's also the funniest person on the
team um and she's amazing and incredible
and i just wanted to call her out today
too you all know vadon i've already done
this i've done this around but don't
okay
uh so cheers for angela for everything
she does
okay zeke sorry sorry to get you off
track there go ahead
um
administration officials said that since
tomorrow the president's going to extend
the student uh
students uh retain it uh
uh for another three months through
august uh
uh
starting a couple months before the
midterm elections is that
is the president willing to sort of end
that pause and have borrowers need to
make payments that close to uh to a
midterm election well uh i
to not get too ahead to where you are at
this point in time it expires in may
obviously we'll have an informal
announcement to make before that
timeline i don't have anything to
preview at this point in time obviously
we look at and assess
what the needs are for the people who
are impacted by the payment of student
loans
as we make these assessments
i would note that no one has been
required to pay a single dime a federal
student loan since the president took
office
and of course the department of
education will continue to communicate
directly with borrowers about federal
student loan repayment and servicers as
we make this final decision on a
different topic um they've heard a lot
of the administration about the lack of
international uh code relief funding for
vaccinations does the president believe
that about this money he can meet this
pledge to the world with global vaccine
sharing um and just you have to
recalibrate that congress seems
unwilling to provide the necessary money
to get there well no we can't meet uh
our uh commitments uh and cannot
continue to be the arsenal of vaccines
to the global community without global
funding a usaid won't have resources to
get more shots and arms we'll be forced
to scale back our work providing oxygen
and anti-viral pills and we will lack
the funding to provide rapid testing to
countries in need it's not just about
vaccine doses of course i know that's
kind of the question you asked it's also
about providing the know-how and the uh
the
the individuals and at times the
training to be able to get shots and
arms and those are programs that we fund
through our global efforts as well and
we need that funding in order to
continue these programs lastly uh for me
uh general milly had some pretty
sobering testimony on the hill uh today
regarding the world and sort of grim
outlook um the potential for significant
international conflict is increasing not
decreasing is that an assessment of the
president's shares
um and is that sort of the assessment of
the us government that's sort of the
state of the world joshua that was when
the president took office well certainly
the uh general milley speaks for uh the
assessment of the us military and i
think that's what he was testifying on
and you know he speaks on behalf of the
administration go ahead
general millie also said that he thinks
the war in ukraine will be measured in
years that this will be a long
protracted conflict
can you clarify do you mean that the
ground war will be lasting years and is
the u.s committed to aiding ukraine for
as long as this drives on well we're
certainly committed to
continuing our historic support of
ukraine whether that is military
assistance humanitarian assistance
economic assistance without further
parsing general millie's words and
certainly i would point you the
department of defense into him directly
i think we also understand that
the recovery from this war the
rebuilding in ukraine uh people who have
lost their homes communities that have
been destroyed is going to take some
time and the united states will
certainly continue to be a part of that
president zolensky today effectively ask
what's the point of the u.n security
council if they can't find a way to hold
russia accountable given russia's veto
power he suggested the council was
powerless and outdated
does he have a point and does the white
house think the security council needs
to be reformed
is that even possible well i think he's
certainly referring to uh i obviously
can speak for himself but uh his
frustration which we share that russia
is a permanent member of the u.n
security council we don't see that
changing and so what our objective
is at this point in time is on a couple
of fronts uh one is to continue to
provide
a range of security assistance uh to
ukraine directly to ukraine to the
military uh that is serving boldly and
bravely on their behalf i can provide
you a little bit of an update on that
that in addition to the deliveries of
the 200 million uh dollar package
announced on march 12th which are almost
complete uh deliveries of the 800
million dollar package the president
announced on march 16th are actively
occurring and obviously the department
of defense has also announced a range of
equipment that is being provided i'd
also note that
there are a range of mechanisms as it
relates to accountability and you know
that relates to the president's
strong statements about his view and
belief that russia and president putin
are are guilty of war crimes and
obviously the atrocities that have taken
place
and they are not necessarily through the
u.n mechanisms and there are obviously
challenges to that given russia is a
permanent member but there are ample
examples uh in the past of other
international bodies and we will
continue to support those efforts as
well i just want more the centuries that
are coming tomorrow being announced by
the u.s and european partners are
expected to target russian government
officials and their family members is
also expected to include putin's
daughters
i don't have more specifics to detail or
preview for you at this point in time it
is expected or you can expect i should
say as many of you have reported that
they will target a russian government
officials their family members
russian-owned financial institutions
also state-owned enterprises it's a part
of the continuation of our efforts to
put consequences in place uh hold uh
hold russian officials accountable and
again those announcements will be made
tomorrow go ahead um thanks jen um
secretary of state lincoln earlier today
said that the killings in bhuta are not
a random act by a rogue unit but that it
is a deliberate campaign
by russia to commit these atrocities but
he did not offer any evidence the u.s
has to back up this claim wondering if
the white house can share any evidence
to that effect well i think what the
secretary was referring to is the fact
that we have predicted and laid out very
clearly the intention of president putin
and the russian military to commit
atrocities that's what they have done we
have seen with our own eyes what they
have done uh that is uh
consistent with but a little different
from a question about a process which is
a process that would take place on the
through an international mechanism uh on
uh
to to have a review or have a
investigation into war crimes that is a
process that we would certainly be
supporting supporting in a range of ways
but what he was speaking to is the fact
that we had predicted it what we
predicted has unfortunately happened and
we've only seen
potentially the tip of the iceberg
because of where we have had access to
we have not have access to
an expanse of the country where they
have likely also committed atrocities
thank you and one quickly on sanctions
um
we've sort of increasingly seen uh seen
evidence that russia is turning to china
to certainly
uh we just had a report uh that reuters
said today about turning to china from
microchips
they're also they have a payment card
that they have now issued uh in
conjunction with the china's union k
which is an alternative payment system
as you're aware and i'm wondering if
what is going to be announced tomorrow
will
uh you know have anything to do with
making china comply with western
sanctions i mean if you can if you can
speak to that that continues to be not
just our expectation but what we've
conveyed directly but these sanctions
are related to russia
go ahead
first on sanctions last night the
tertiary department
shifted their general licenses a little
bit in terms of payments yeah
from foreign reserves in u.s
institutions is it fair to say that the
goal right now is to have a sovereign
default with russia in terms of how you
want to impose costs
the goal is to force them to make a
choice so russia does not have unlimited
resources especially now given the
crippling sanctions we've put in place
and they are going to be forced to
choose between draining remaining
valuable dollar reserves or new revenue
coming in or default
uh part of our objective here the
biggest part of our objective here is to
deplete the resources that putin has to
continue his war against ukraine
and obviously causing more certainty
uncertainty and challenges to their
financial system is a part of that but
it is forcing them to choose those
options and to also deplete the
resources making it more difficult for
him to continue to fight the war longer
term jake yesterday said something along
the lines of this is not the time for
complacency i understand the alliance
that's been put together over the last
six months doesn't have a lot of
precedent but how real is the concern
that if this is protracted if this is
months not weeks um that fractures could
end up
coming to pass in the alliance who gets
put together
we have been very clear-eyed about that
possibility from the beginning which is
why there has been so much effort on the
diplomatic front to
work at it
including obviously the president's trip
to europe uh secretary blinken is on his
way or maybe he's there now in europe uh
there are calls that happen every single
day through nearly every national
security official to continue to work
towards uh that coordinated unity that
has been so effective to date
it is also true though that
unity does not mean identical and as
we're looking at the consequences people
are putting place the actions they're
taking uh our expectation is not that it
is identical it is just our effort to do
everything we can to make sure it's
coordinated and as unified as it
possibly can be last one real quick i
think you addressed it yesterday so i
apologize but when you talk about the
bridge from the sbr perspective is it a
bridge to you believe the domestic
industry will be able to fill
that gap within the next six months or
is it a bridge to domestic plus canada
plus the middle east how are you guys
seeing what that is the bridge to in
terms of production
a combination i would say phil as you
know the oil market is a global market
and we certainly uh understand and have
seen that obviously the actions of
president putin have has led to an
increase in gas prices not just here in
the united states but in other countries
in the world we also know that as other
countries make decisions about energy
sanctions that could have an impact on
the amount of supply in the marketplace
so we are taking steps that uh obviously
a historic release from the strategic
petroleum reserve over the next six
months to hopefully give a bridge to
domestic increased domestic production
to your point which we know could take a
little bit of time but also during that
time we're also working with other
countries around the world you saw the
announcement many of them made last week
about their increased releases but also
to see what they can do to increase
their supply into the marketplace as
we're filling that gap glad
yes um today secretary blinken also said
that the us was continuing to gather
evidence and will continue to support
ukraine the u.n human rights council as
it relates to a possible war crime trial
i know yesterday jake said the u.s was
looking at a variety of mechanisms but
since the u.s is not party to the icc
other than a supportive rule what can it
do
to facilitate a trial
well let me give you an update on where
we are and i would also let me first
point to the fact that historically we
have uh provided evidence to the icc
even though we are not a party member so
if you look back in 2004 uh the state
department collected evidence indicating
that the sudanese military uh and
militias were committing specific acts
of violence against members of non-arab
groups in darfur and the secretary of
state at the time colin powell
determined that what was happening was
uh was a genocide we worked with the icc
and the u.n security council to hold
accountable so i would just note there
is historic reference now also as you're
thinking about the timeline of this the
historic reference for that is also
important because that literally that
was 2004 and it is just starting now so
it takes time now it doesn't always take
that amount of time but just you know as
you're looking at the history here but
right now there are a number of efforts
already underway uh to hold any russians
accountable for atrocities and war
crimes over the past few weeks we
established investigations through the
u.n human rights council and the oste of
possible violations by russia we're also
supporting the work of the war crimes
unit under the office of the ukrainian
prosecutor general and a team of
international prosecutors who are
working with them and also supporting
ukraine's authorities and civil society
organizations who are working on the
grounds document atrocity crimes for
prosecution we also welcome the
investigation opened by the icc
prosecutor in particular his focus on
preserving evidence of possible atrocity
crimes and as you noted jake outlined
the specific ways that we can help in
those efforts including uh
through intelligence sources and
gathering and sharing that with our
partners including uh helping ukrainians
and what they're doing on the ground to
develop their case
third is working through international
organizations and the fourth as he noted
yesterday as all of you and and the
range of important reporting and sharing
of images uh and information gathering
that's happening out there but those are
the different uh different options and
different mechanisms we're working
through now but it has not yet been
determined what the international
mechanism is and you mentioned that's
going to take a lot of time um it seems
that you've also
indicated that
every sanctions package is not meant to
be an on and off switch to stop putin
but that will also take time is there
anything that can be done to stop putin
now in the immediate i would say first
on sanctions we have a couple of
objectives one of them is to put
consequences in place uh put a marker
down and make very clear it's absolutely
unacceptable horrific and there should
be consequences the second is to make it
more difficult to fund the ongoing war
and that is a very important component
and the question phil asked earlier
about the bond payments and the bond
payment that is due is an example of
that and the mechanisms the mechanisms
we have there are economic uh resources
to do exactly that and the third is to
make clear and make it evident to
president putin and russian leadership
in the world that he is a pariah and now
is uh and and will be held accountable
and treated in that way on the global
stage um but what we're what we feel is
the most effective thing we can do now
in addition to that is to continue to
provide military assistance security
assistance equipment on the ground i
would note again the department of
defense announced a series of additional
military pieces of equipment that they
had not private previously delivered
that they were delivering to the grounds
and we are focusing that effort on
ensuring it is equipment that ukrainians
are trained on and that they have
already been using effectively in this
war to fight the russians good and just
to follow up on luigi's question you
guys are adding more sanctions saying
that the sanctions are going to take
time to have an impact how much time do
you guys think that these innocent
ukrainians have
well i think what's important to note
here is sanctions are just one component
of the tools that we have at our
disposal what we are doing and we're
already seeing effectively happen is the
financial system in russia is near the
brink of collapse i mean they're
projecting 15 percent inflation a
contraction of 15
in their economy uh private sector
businesses are pulling out of the
country it is more and more difficult
for president putin to fund this war
every single day that has an impact but
what we're also doing is providing
historic amount of military and security
assistance which is what they've been
using effectively over the last few
weeks to fight this war and push back
the russians but do you guys assess that
anything you've done so far has
prevented a war crime from happening
well peter i would say that everything
we're doing to date is to support the
ukrainians in this war and in this
effort and that is something the
president's proud of we are proud of
including rallying and leading the
global community and standing up against
russia on another topic a lot of stories
about hunter biden surfacing this week
so to ensure the independence of the
investigation would the president
support the appointment of a special
counsel
well first the president has never had a
conversation with the department of
justice about any investigations into
any member of his family he said that
during the campaign and he will continue
to abide by that so i'd point to the
department of justice for any additional
steps they would take they would make
those decisions independently is there
any concern that they're not going to be
necessarily seen as being able to make
the decisions independently the white
house chief of staff is out saying that
the president is confident his son did
not break the law
well that's something the president has
said and certainly we would echo but in
the same answer to that question peter
during an interview this week on abc ron
clayne also said the justice department
is independent and they will make their
own decisions the president has said
that he never
spoke to his son about his overseas
business dealings is that still the case
yes
good
so tomorrow you're going to announce the
white house is going to announce new
sanctions administration will do
sanctions on russia in some form should
we view those sanctions as a response to
bucha or how should we view those when
they're announced well unfortunately the
the photos the horrific photos we've
seen from bush are not the first uh
violation of war crimes or or atrocities
that we've seen take place on the ground
so in part
yes but they have been in the works and
part of our process of putting in place
consequences to say there may be more
should we anticipate more in terms of
reaction to bucha this wouldn't be it in
isolation correct we are continuing to
assess and make decisions about
additional consequences and steps we can
put in place so given these awful videos
and pictures we're seeing of the
atrocities that took place in butcher
right now
is the u.s policy still one of no regime
change in russia and if so why should
someone like vladimir putin be viewed by
the us as someone who should be allowed
to stay in power well i think our policy
is no we are not calling for regime
change and that that has not been our
policy and continues not to be our
policy but again peter our view is that
he is a war criminal and he is somebody
who should be uh looked at by the
international uh system who evaluates
war crimes i guess the question people
say then why not be a worker why should
we be allowed to stand out well our
policy is not to call for regime change
we're not calling for regime change but
again he is somebody who's committed
atrocities against the people in his
country he's a pariah in the world and
every step we've taken has made that
clear to the global community very
quickly can you pull back the curtain of
what happened upstairs when we weren't
watching between the former president
and the current president over lunch did
they talk about food in ukraine did they
do a tour of the residence what can you
tell us about their time together you
know i haven't had a chance to download
yet with the president i did see a
former president briefly but he is his
schedule's a little lighter than the
current presidents these days um i do
know that they had a great expansive
conversation i haven't downloaded on the
specifics of it yet i'm not sure i'll be
able to share those with all of you uh
they did go take a look at the oval
office and take a walk around and i know
they enjoyed spending time together
just to put a finer point on some of the
questions you've so far been asked why
shouldn't the images of the atrocities
compel a worldwide unified
coalition kinetic response you mean a
military war tell me more about what you
mean
a military response led by the united
states and the international party as in
bringing military troops on the ground
from the united states and nato well the
president described outrageous things
you'd call them atrocities you've said
perhaps we should brace ourselves for
worse
why not
i think what the president's uh
objective is and his responsibility is
to make decisions that are in the
interests of the united states and the
national security of the united states
and the american people and that is not
to go to war with russia it is to do
everything in our power
to hold them accountable to support
efforts through international systems to
do exactly that and to provide military
assistance security assistance and
support to the ukrainian people and the
ukrainian government that's exactly what
we're doing but it is not in our
interests or in the interest of the
american people for us to be in a war
with russia go ahead to follow up on
phil's question on the russian sovereign
debt does the white house have any sense
of timing on when russia might default i
don't have an assessment of that i will
be looking forward to reading
bloomberg's assessment of that but i
don't have an assessment of that from
here
it depends in part on what decisions
they make on what decisions okay and
then on the federal reserve search is
the white house still searching for a
nominee to replace sarah bloom raskin
and when are you expecting to make an
announcement
my understanding of the process is it's
ongoing i don't have an update on the
timeline of when that would be concluded
um question on sanctions new ones that
you're going to announce this week um
can you is there anything you can tell
us about them
and just to follow up if china and
brazil and india and the middle east are
not participating how effective can they
be well tomorrow what we're going to
announce is what i can tell you and it
may not be fully satisfying but let me
do my best
in coordination with the g7 and eu an
additional sweeping package of sanctions
measures that will impose costs in
russia send it further down the road of
economic financial and technological
isolation
this will include a ban on all new
investment in russia and increased
sanctions on financial institutions and
state-owned enterprises in russia and
sanctions on russian government
officials and their family members these
measures will degrade key instruments of
russian state power and pose acute and
immediate economic harm in on russia and
holds accountable the russian
kleptocracy that funds and supports
putin's war so this is going to be done
in coordination with others and those
the steps will be targeting as i as i
just noted obviously family members uh
russian uh government officials and
other state-owned enterprises and
financial institutions pretty big
economies that are not participating
again i think what we're doing is we're
working to rally the world and taking
steps to hold russia accountable does
not mean they're identical it doesn't
mean they'll all happen on the exact
same timeline but that is what we're
continuing to work to do from here about
the countries that are absolutely not
participating
like china and brazil and india i
understand what you're asking i
understand what you're asking what i'm
conveying is that we are also
coordinating with the g7 in the eu which
is about fifty percent of the global
economy which is still a significant uh
unified entity and holding russia
accountable and in our conversations
obviously we had
our deputy national security adviser
traveled to india recently to convey the
implementation of our own sanctions and
our expectation is not only that other
countries will abide by uh but that they
will also uh
be a constructive part of holding russia
accountable go ahead thank you so much
um i just a question to see if you have
any reaction to victor orban's victory
and
what kind of message that may send to
um allies in in europe
let me check with our national security
team i'm sure we can get you a direct
reaction to it
i just wanted to ask
the president is seeing any sort of
having any new um restrictions or if
there are any procedures that that are
in place just given there have been a
number of staff the white house who have
clothed the reporters who have covered
many of them were mixing this weekend at
a dinner is that who she did not attend
but not attend but she did not attend
but is there any sort of additional
heightened concern just given this
moment and the fact that a lot of people
at this house didn't be getting it well
we know that um ba2 which is the
dominant variant is a very transmissible
variant and so we've obviously been
watching that and watching that closely
and certainly we knew that as it has
been the case in the in the broader
population including among the media but
also among staff that means that there
will be people
who get kovid
who are fully vaccinated and have been
boosted especially in the white house
and i think with most members of the
media as well so fortunately what we're
seeing is largely mild symptoms but
what we do the policies we do here which
we we have not changed but they are more
stringent than the cdc so just to
reiterate for all of you um
the our policy is that all uh executive
office of the present employees
surrounding the president uh are on a
regular testing schedule to screen for
covet on campus that is a step beyond
cdc guidance if you're going to see the
president you will be tested that day
even if you're not traveling with him
just if you're going to see him for a
meeting the president's doctor will
continue to determine if additional
testing is needed on any given week in
light of various considerations for
example because of the travel from a
couple of weeks ago he was tested in
addition to his regular cadence after he
came back uh and importantly um as i
noted everyone going to a meeting with
one of any of the four principals is
obviously tested
in addition for those employees who test
positive and i can confirm this two
times over
they're required to isolate an alignment
with cdc guidance must test negative
before returning to work that's a step
beyond what cdc
recommends and if they test negative
under 10 under 10 days they're required
to wear a mask for that period of time
as well
and meetings
with the president are often socially
distanced uh in many circumstances as an
additional precaution even as people are
tested so there are a range of stats my
point is i sorry that was a lot of a lot
of a list but is that we take a range of
steps we have been taking a range of
steps that um that are meant to uh put
an extra layer uh on in protecting the
four principles and given it is the
white house is there any um thought to
having the president take any medication
prophylactically in case that he is in
contact with
not that i'm aware of i don't even know
what that would be but not that not that
i am aware of uh he
he he obviously he he relies on the
advice of his doctor but not that i'm
aware of go ahead yeah thanks jen
senators romney murkowski yesterday
announced their support uh uh to her
plans to vote to confirm judge jackson
uh later this week or perhaps next week
um well we'll leave this week because
they're going on recess
or don't tell senators you said that
what is your reaction to what you heard
from senators romney murkowski there and
it looks uh
likely that that she will get three
republican
votes in support is the white house
believe that that's a strong showing of
bipartisan support for that for her or
you know the fact that 47 republicans
appear likely to vote against her um you
know are you displeased with
the lack of support of republicans well
i would note first that even for a
number of senators who decided not to
support her and there's quite a good
little video the daily show may or may
not have done on this um
all of them talked about her impeccable
credentials her qualifications um what
an incredibly inspiring uh story she has
uh and how qualified she is for the job
i would say we believe we believe from
the beginning that her record uh her
impeccable credentials warranted
bipartisan support and that is exactly
what she is going to get in her
confirmation
thanks to those individuals and one more
that had previously announced their
support so we're certainly encouraged by
that we're looking forward to seeing her
confirmed and of course celebrating her
uh her confirmation to the supreme court
thanks jen um the cdc director
announcement she's going to be doing a
review of the agency uh and revamp after
they see
what has worked and what hasn't worked
is there something specific that the cdc
has been doing wrong or some area where
it's been falling short that's prompted
this need to have such an intense review
right now sure well let me first say
this is a cdc driven decision
and uh they'd have more specifics but
what i would say is that if you look
back to the last year plus uh never in
its 75 year history has the cdc had to
make decisions so quickly uh based on
limited real time and evolving science
and yesterday with the cdc director did
is rightfully announced plans to
initiate a review of the agency to with
the objective of strengthening
transforming and modernizing cdc systems
and processes around developing and
deploying its science i mean look at
what they've done over the last year
does it mean everything has been perfect
they would say no you have to look at
how it's done assess that and and and
take a look at how you're going to
improve things anything you need to
moving forward um it's not uncommon for
a cdc director to take a careful look at
the agency and assess if it's positioned
to meet current public health needs and
recommend improvements to systems
processes and structures and while this
is something that is being done
independent of the white house we
certainly support all government working
to improve systems and make things
better independent you said it was a cbc
driven decision so this call for the
review did not come from the white house
no it was a it was cdc driven and one uh
and certainly one we support but the uh
process will be led by the cdc go ahead
and republicans are calling for an
amendment on title 42 to be attached to
the public relief funding bill i just
wanted to get the white house reaction
to that but then also what kind of
effects are you guys worried about if
this funding measure gets married and
doesn't pass well i think my uh
colleague i don't know he seems senior
to me jeff zion said this um what he
said in response that to this question
is that decisions on title 42 should
remain independent of the urgently
needed funding for covet aid i mean this
is a decision made by the cdc it's a
public health decision uh it's not one
that should be uh wrapped up of course
in politics and the decisions made by
the cdc is is where it should be long as
it relates to title 42. i would note on
your earlier question um
you know the impact of not uh getting
this
this aid
would be uh would be significant
right now these additional resources are
urgently needed for our domestic
response including just to give you a
sense of some examples of how it would
be used booster shots for the general
population monoclonal antibodies and
evasheld for the immunocompromised
maintaining our testing capacity these
are all components that are vital to our
continued fight uh against uh against
the pandemic and uh you know these are
efforts that shouldn't be political um
they shouldn't be controversial uh we're
all certainly coveted 19 doesn't look at
your party affiliation before they
decide to uh before it decides to
inflict you uh with the virus um and so
uh they're vital we need this funding
and we'll have to stop as i've noted in
him before a number of these important
programs uh if we don't get the funding
thank you good morning thank you
i'm trying to understand uh how you see
this these horrible this horrible news
coming out of ukraine with the
these massacres
i'd like to understand do you see it as
something fundamentally
like a game changer
or is it just another incremental you
know awfulness and the thing that's been
going on for you know whatever a month
uh and if it is something fundamentally
different
these people their hands tied and thrown
into pits and sellers and whatever
um
does that mean that that we can expect
to be hearing a fundamentally different
response because that's also been also
incremental
well i would say first that there's
nothing normal there's nothing
acceptable there's nothing that
shouldn't
shake people to their core about the
photos they're seeing of what is
happening on the ground or what has
happened i should say on the ground
and what the president has said and been
unquestionable about is that these are
war crimes a violation of
the law of war and his view and i talked
about this as recently as this morning
is that we need to put down a marker for
history that's why he has been so
outspoken about this and made clear that
accountability is critically important
uh when you see the horror that we're
seeing on the ground the targeting of
hospitals of civilians uh of as you
noted the binding and killing of
innocent people in bucha that where
we're seeing the photos uh we have al
though also already seen evidence of war
crimes before these photos and a lot of
the measures that we're putting in place
uh whether it is supporting
international efforts to work towards
gathering data and information through a
range of mechanisms or it is continuing
to provide additional security
assistance or humanitarian assistance or
in response to the atrocities and the
horrors we're seeing on the ground go
ahead
yeah i wanted to ask you about el
salvador about the state of exception
that has been imposed in el salvador um
um
this state suspends constitutional
guarantees such as the right to assemble
and also basic procedural rights for the
salvadoran people is the u.s concerned
about the impact of this measure
so i would say can you act sorry can you
ask your question one more time i wanted
to make sure i had the right information
though of course yes yeah it's about the
state of exception that was in person el
salvador which
suspends constitutional guarantees such
as the right to assemble and also basic
procedural rights for the salvadoran
people wanting to see if the u.s is
concerned about this
let me check with our national security
team and get more details for you and we
will get you a more comprehensive uh
comment after the briefing go ahead
thanks jen i have a few for you start
with the supreme court yeah that took
place yesterday is the president
disappointed in particular that senator
lindsey graham who had voted for judge
jackson before opted to vote against her
yesterday the president is looking
forward to judge jackson getting
confirmed and i would say as i said echo
what i said yesterday which is this is a
question best posed to senator lindsey
graham what exactly has changed since he
voted to support her uh just
recently relatively recently she has the
exact same credentials exact same
qualifications so no i wouldn't say the
president's spending a lot of time
thinking about it but i would say it's a
good question to pose to senator graham
topic i won't get into all the
president's polling but i did want to
ask you if you see the expected
confirmation of judge jackson as a
turning point in his presidency
i would say without getting into the
politics of it the president committed
to
nominate a african-american woman to
serve on the supreme court if there was
an opening we are on the verge of that
woman getting confirmed to the supreme
court this is a moment even with
everything going on in the world to
celebrate history to celebrate this
incredible woman who has impeccable
credentials who is about to serve on the
supreme court and so certainly we're
going to take a moment to appreciate
that and value that and i think a lot of
people in this country will too i can't
make a prediction on what that will mean
for polls and it's really not about that
for us
president obama former president obama
did seem to get to the politics of it
today when he was talking about his uh
own re-election battle and seem to be
delivering somewhat of a pep talk for
democrats facing potentially tough
re-election battles in the midterms this
year is that a message that the white
house wanted him to come here and
deliver today well having worked for the
former president for some time and the
new the newer president for some time as
well here's what i heard him talking
about uh the fact that in washington
when you're pushing for getting the
right thing done and he was talking
about the affordable care act it means
sometimes overcoming skepticism
republican obstruction
even division within your own party
political challenges countless headlines
saying your agenda is dead and still
fighting to get it done sounds pretty
similar to what we're working on today
that's not about the midterms that's
about why you're in government and
making government work for people and
why it's important to continue to do
even when everybody says it's not
possible and that was the message i
think he was delivering today go ahead
thank you jen um i have two questions on
ukraine prime minister justin trudeau
said last week that he does not want
president putin to attend the g20
meetings and he has reached out to
indonesian president joko widodo who is
the host of this year's meetings so does
president biden have uh plans to also do
the same to reach out personally to the
indonesian president and can you just
share anything on the diplomatic front
in terms of trying to get russia out of
the g20 meetings or or get ukraine in as
an observer sure i don't have any update
on that i'm happy to see if we have any
update from our front and just a
follow-up uh on a different note on
ukraine china today
urged the u.n security council to verify
and not to resort to
unfounded conclusions on bucha and
meanwhile chinese media is also
repeating russia's narrative that what's
happened in bucha is fake news can we
get a white house reaction on that i
would just say if you're repeating the
propaganda of the russian government and
president putin you're on the wrong side
of history thank you jen um last week a
senior treasury official briefed that
the sanctions on russia were originally
intended to deter but now the point of
the sanctions is intended to debilitate
and impair the war effort can you
elaborate on any change in
messaging around the sanctions and their
intended purpose and how that's changed
sure well look i think the way we always
saw it from the beginning is that uh the
threat of sanctions uh you know your
hope is that there is a deterrence
effect that has been played out in
history that there has been a deterrence
effect at times that is not a sure thing
or 100
but if it reduces or if it makes a
leader
potentially think about what actions
what horrific actions they're going to
take then they're worth that threat of
sanctions never has it been the case
that the putting sanctions in place is
it is effective deterrent the threat of
them has been an effective deterrent
obviously the war has commenced right
and
sanctions have always had the purpose of
putting in place consequences so right
now those consequences also include
making it very difficult for president
putin to fund the war which as you know
includes uh steps like the step taken by
the department of treasury yesterday
where they're going to be forced because
they don't have unlimited resources to
make choices about how they're going to
spend the resources they have how do you
describe these latest rounds of
sanctions because the administration was
very clear in the beginning that if the
invasion happened that it would bring
forth everything but the kitchen sink so
the sanctions that we're seeing rolled
out now how would you describe them are
they simply incremental at this point
well the russian there are they've all
been building on each other the russian
economy is on at the brink of collapse
uh the uh inflation is
skyrocketing at 15 percent the
detraction of the construction of the
economy there is also projecting to
decrease by 15
private sector businesses are not
investing in russia and the president is
a president putin is a pariah this has
all been the result of a coordinated
global effort to put in place economic
and financial consequences that are
having
incredible effect in addition we have
made it much more difficult because of
export controls and other limitations on
the type of materials that president
putin and the russians can purchase
to to build the technological systems
and capacities to fight wars in addition
to funding wars um and those are all
components that have been the result of
the efforts to date go ahead
i wanted to ask um about your long covet
announcement earlier today
the criticism that's come from lawmakers
has been that it's going to take a long
time to collect data and studies on long
coverage can you talk about how this
memo helps people that are living with
that now
i think this is um an effort to
acknowledge um that
this is something that many people in
this country are suffering from and
dealing with and
unfortunately science moves at the pace
of science and it is acknowledgment of
that and a commitment by the us
government to take steps to look at it
more closely and see what more we can do
to help address and help people who have
been suffering go ahead and i want us to
ask about refugees i had asked yesterday
about the 100 000 number you were
talking about how the administration's
response has been geared toward refugees
staying in nearby countries can you talk
about though how you got to that hundred
thousand number does that have anything
to do with the capacity of the us
government to take in people that are
not exactly what i said yesterday but
what i said was there is a an ongoing
policy process that hopefully will be
concluded soon and we'll have more to
share with all of you soon about the
prioritization and how the process will
work for these ref ukrainian refugees
who will be eligible
in terms of the number this is an effort
by the president and the united states
to
welcome
through a through an expedited process
and a different process that we'll have
more details on soon ukrainian refugees
into the united states even as we know
factually that the vast majority of them
will want to and have expressed an
interest in staying in countries nearby
so it is just an effort to
make clear our willingness and openness
to doing that
can you guys give us a sense of how
president biden will mark uh judge
jackson's confirmation later this week i
i expect we'll have more details in the
coming uh 24 to 48 hours on that but i
don't have anything to preview at this
point in time
there's momentum in the european union
to ban all natural gas coming from
europe they're not taking that step but
there's momentum the european commission
is changing regulations to accelerate
approvals for their natural gas
infrastructure in the announcement in
brussels the u.s said they're going to
keep the regulatory framework so how is
the us going to continually support
enough natural gas should europe cut off
the russian flow in order to long-term
handle to help our european neighbors
well there are steps we've already taken
in preparation that we will build on and
we will continue to explore ways to
ensure that
european countries are not as reliant as
they have been on russia for natural gas
and for a range of energy resources one
of the steps we've taken successfully
which we will continue to build on is to
tap into countries in asia who have uh
lng excess lng capacity to provide that
to europe that is something we've
already done to date and we will
continue to explore we've been working
on this for months in anticipation of a
potential shortage or potential needs in
europe how about infrastructure projects
in the us though
to help expand them facilitate them go
forward and tell me more about what you
mean exactly um senator capitao to
increase capacity lng capacity yes uh i
i can check with our team and see if
there's anything to preview on that
anymore go ahead george yeah there was a
recent poll that showed more people
think jobs were lost in the last year
than think uh jobs were gained
why is that and is there anything that
you can do to change that perception
well i saw that poll um or saw that data
um what i can tell you uh what we can do
from here is share the facts and i know
all of you are working to share facts as
well even as you ask us tough questions
and hold us accountable into account as
well we know the fact is that the
president created more jobs last year
than any year in american history
that is a very simple fact that i
probably cannot say enough from here and
our allies and partners cannot say
enough out there in the country um and
we will just continue have to continue
to work at it why is the belief out
there though i can't make a clear
assessment of that george you know i
know that obviously people across the
country we know and we see this in data
and polling are still feeling the impact
of covid their lives are not entirely
back to normal
they're seeing some
you know restrictions to their daily
living which is frustrating obviously
the impact of the cost of items whether
it's the price of gas that has a range
of factors that have led to it
specifically the invasion of ukraine
most recently
those impact how people feel we see that
in consumer confidence so i i can't
assess what is in the brain of every
american but i can tell you what the
facts are and tell you that we also
recognize that there are areas including
bringing down costs will continue to
work out everything go ahead thank you
um
two quick questions one the president is
talking about congress passing more
money for code relief but what's the
president's reaction to more cities
taking covert relief money and putting
it towards policing in excessive amounts
specifically even like in dekalb county
where a half a million was spent on
aerial drones i mean is the president
thinking that's a bit of an abusive fund
is he okay with that kind of spending i
haven't seen that report i'd have to
look into that specifically more i mean
there's state and local funding that has
gone out through the american rescue
plan where there is flexibility in there
including to support state and local
governments i don't know if that is what
is being used for but i'm happy to check
into the more specific reports
my last question i wanted to ask this a
couple of weeks ago but i wanted to go
back to haiti very quickly to get the
president's response um patrol agents
that were seeing whipping haitian
migrants were not charged and held
accountable for actions even the
president um early on talked about how
it was outrageous how does he what's his
reaction to that response to those who
saw this core horrific video go viral
and then at the end of the day nothing
happens there's no accountability there
was an investigation by the department
of homeland security so i'd have you uh
point you to them for any further
comment on it go ahead
thank you um two weeks ago the president
warned the american people and owners
and operators of critical infrastructure
that russians cyber attacks were
coming
and he urged those owners and operators
to harden their cyber defenses is there
any update intelligence update that you
can give to the american people and
critical infrastructure operators about
this
pretty urgent warning that that came
recently well i don't have any
additional intelligence to update you on
from here but the reason we did that at
the time is because
there are steps we can take from the
federal government but there is also
steps that private sector companies can
and need to take uh in order to protect
themselves those don't typically happen
overnight so we wanted to ensure they
understood that these threats are real
that it was urgent that they take these
steps but i don't have anything in
addition to predict about uh next steps
or intelligence
operators that you can talk about
there is ongoing work uh that our cyber
team uh has been doing from the
beginning of the administration working
closely with the private sector that's
been a huge priority for the president
the recognition that it needs to be a
partnership and one of the reasons we go
out publicly as we do is because even as
we're and that was actually on the heels
of when ann neuberger came here it was
on the heels of a briefing she had done
with larger institutions to talk about
this we also recognized though that
cyber attacks can impact smaller
institutions medium-sized institutions
and institutions that uh you know need
to know that there are easy steps they
can take to center to two-factor
authentication uh passwords not clicking
on mysterious links that can also help
protect themselves so that's why we went
out publicly to spread the message
broadly thank you so much everyone
i remember
you